meine herren meine damen da wir uns nun
endgültig der perspektive der
praktischen philosophie zuwenden möchte
ich meinen vortrag mit einigen ihrer
grundsätzlichen bemerkungen zum
verhältnis von anthropologie und
philosophie einleiten wie wohl york das
in seiner in seinem vortrag auch schon
getan hat um dann eine zeitgenössische
debatte über die überwindung der
menschlichen lebens forum aufzugreifen
und ihre ethischen implikationen zu
thematisieren weil mir das dann im
dritten teil die möglichkeit geben wird
eine ja nicht das erotische sondern meta
philosophische thesen über die
anthropologischen das können wir dann
vielleicht zu nennen anthropologischen
ausgangs und bezugspunkte unserer
normativen theoriebildung und damit auch
eine bestimmte these über den status der
menschlichen natur oder der natur der
menschlichen lebens form als eine quelle
für normen zu formulieren und ich
beginne
erstens mit dem schwierigen wandelbaren
gleichwohl enge verhältnis von
praktischer philosophie und
anthropologie anthropologie als
wissenschaft vom menschen hat wie jörg
dollar schon sagte einen schweren stand
innerhalb der philosophie der gegenwart
und die gründe hierfür liegen auf der
hand
zuvorderst sind sie methodologische art
denn eine abgrenzung der
geisteswissenschaftlichen anthropologie
von ihren empirischen schwestern feld
chronisch schwer ebenso ihre etablierung
als eine eigenständige philosophische
disziplin die sich ja als eine solche
disziplinen charakterisieren lassen
müsste durch spezifische
problemstellungen durch besondere
grundbegriffe und die ist dann auch
erlauben würden diese disziplin von den
anderen teildisziplinen der philosophie
zu unterscheiden
ja und überhaupt zeigt er schon ein
kurzer blick in die philosophie
geschichte
dass es sich bei der anthropologie um
ein vergleichsweise junges ansinnen
handelt dass seine disziplin ehre
dynamik erst spät nämlich im ausgehenden
jahrhundert entfaltet bis zu einem
vorläufigen höhepunkt in den ersten
jahrzehnten des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ich denke hier an die im wesentlichen
deutsche philosophische groß
geschriebene anthropologie von plessner
gehen schiller oder dem na ja in
gewisser hinsicht pondorf im
amerikanischen pragmatismus von john
dewey und nun aber das ist auch schon
wieder ziemlich lange her und das ist
nicht grundlos so meine ich denn gegen
die verschränkung von philosophie und
anthropologie drängen sich zu diesen
naja hartnäckigen methodologischen
problemen auch noch andere auf
zuvorderst der verdacht des
kulturrelativismus oder der ideologie
blindheit also das was jürgen habermas
in der mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts mit wirklich großen
einfluss für die deutschsprachige
diskussion festgestellt hat in einem
lexikon eintrag nämlich dass ich zitiere
über das wesen des menschen sich nichts
geradewegs also allgemein neutral
verbindlich gewissermaßen von anderen
youtube konzeption auf riesen aus sagen
lässt sondern immer nur über den weg
oder umweg des deutens sinnstiftend sich
so und so verstehen zitat ende
nun solche hermeneutische umwege über
die sozialwissenschaften kultur und
geschichtswissenschaften erlauben keine
verallgemeinerung erlauben keine
objektivierung demnach kann
philosophische anthropologie richtig
verstanden eigentlich immer nur eine
philosophische kritik der anthropologie
und dh der kontingenten
gesellschaftlichen menschenbilder die
sich sozusagen als wunschbild
herausstellen sei noch eine zweite
besonders hartnäckige herausforderung
die im zuge der diskussion von thomas
vortrag hier schon aufgaben nämlich und
eine herausforderung die jede zukünftige
anthropologie die als philosophie wird
auftreten können bewältigen muss und das
ist der naturalismus der naturalismus in
seinen vielfältigen spielarten sei es
ein metaphysischer naturalismus also
eine ontologische these darüber wie die
welt beschaffen ist nämlich simpel
gesagt raum zeitlich materiell oder sei
es ein zentis tischer naturalismus also
eine methodologische und
epidemiologische theorie darüber was es
überhaupt und in welchem modus zu wissen
gibt nämlich alles und nur das was der
naturwissenschaftlichen methoden und
naturwissenschaftlichen letztlich
physikalischen begriffen zugänglich ist
diese form des naturalismus wie sie ja
in der theoretischen philosophie mit
großer selbstverständlichkeit vertreten
werden sind für das unternehmen einer
philosophischen anthropologie er
vermutlich für die praktische
philosophie im ganzen letztendlich
tödlich jedenfalls wenn praktische
philosophie etwas anderes oder mehr sein
will als mieter ethik und so einfach
weil diesen formen des naturalismus eine
reduktionistischen tendenz innewohnt ich
glaube sogar dass das die attraktivität
des theoretischen naturalismus ausmacht
diese form der vereinfachung oder
natural easy rung wie sie gesagt haben
daher meint naturalismus in der
praktischen philosophie auch etwas
anderes etwa im neo aristotelischen
naturalismus von philipp erfurt eine
ethische theorie die auf zitiere
tatsachen des menschlichen lebens auf
welche gerade nicht los empirisch
naturwissenschaftlich erfasst werden
können die aber für die natur der
menschlichen lebens form konstitutiv
sind wesen stimmen sind und daher für
den individuellen menschen als norm als
normen des gutscheins oder der effizienz
fungieren können also die diesen
programm zu gründen die zu grunde
gelegte anthropologie ist ein brett ein
empirisch evaluationen und ich glaube
das ist als solches auch seine rechte
berechtigung hat nur das sagen ganz
simpel gesagt der verdacht eines sein
sollen fehl- schlosses oder jedenfalls
einer lehrstelle einer argumentativen
lehrstelle zwischen der behauptung von
natürlichen normen oder dieser form der
normativität und gen ethischen normen
also moralischer normativität etwas ist
womit ethische naturalisten wirklich
kämpfen und das ist der aristotelische
ethische naturalismus diese probleme
auch nicht auszuräumen vermag aber das
ist gar nicht der gegenstand meines
vortrages denn ich möchte fragen ob
unter diesen jetzt kurz gezielten
problematischen also meteorologischen
disziplin ehren argumentativen und
begründung theoretischen bedingungen
philosophische anthropologie möglich
oder gar nötig ist
gerade weil für das gros der
akademischen philosophie die antwort
lange und vielleicht auch die längere
zeit negativ ausgefallen ist und der
erkenntniswert einer genuin
philosophischen anthropologie gering
erschien erscheint es bemerkenswert dass
in den letzten zwei jahrzehnten in der
praktischen philosophie auf
anthropologische topoi argumentation
figuren frage stellen
bezug genommen wird ob dieses jetzt
schon anlass bietet von einem einzelfall
deutsche kultur in der philosophie oder
gar der wissenschaften im ganzen zu
sprechen wie man ist ja vielfach hören
und lesen kann
das kann meines erachtens gegenwärtig
noch gar nicht beantwortet werden
jedenfalls ist die anthropologische
grundfrage was ist der mensch für die
philosophie natürlich nicht neu sondern
disziplin und identitätsstiftend anders
gesagt vom menschen handelt die
philosophie immer schon und sowieso jede
theoretische und praktische philosophie
bezieht sich auf ein bestimmtes
verständnis des menschen oder setzt
dieses voraus das ist in einem trivialen
sinne philosophische anthropologie aber
natürlich nicht das was mit
anthropologischen gemeint ist also
dennoch da in den zeitgenössischen
debatten die natur und normen der
menschlichen lebens form nämlich das
menschliche und auch das übermenschliche
verhandelt werden
das heißt die voraussetzung die merkmale
die spezifika des menschseins einerseits
dann aber auch die fiktiven entwürfe
transformation und utopien des
menschlichen andererseits können diese
debatten durchaus anthropologisch
genannt werden und ich möchte ihnen das
demonstrieren an einer ausgewählten
debatte die initiiert wurde durch eine
außerordentliche naturalistische
provokation die die natur der
menschlichen lebens form in frage stellt
und zwar in bislang ungekannter weise
das ist der zweite teil meines vortrages
wer wir sind und was wir werden können
der auslöser für diese debatte sind
bestimmte entwicklungen in den
lebenswissenschaften die auch die
biotechnologischen
interventionsmöglichkeiten die mit
konvergierenden technologien einhergehen
die eben bislang ungekannte nämlich
transformative interviews
interventionsmöglichkeiten in unsere
verfasste halt in unsere körperliche
kognitive psychische und genetische
verfasstheit in aussicht stellen
unter dem stichwort jungen und horns mit
wird diese möglichkeit seit den 1990 er
jahren diskutiert wobei man eben
abgrenzung von medizinischer therapie
und prävention als in horns mit
bezeichnet die technische medizinisch
biologische oder pharmazeutische
optimierung des menschen
das heißt die verbesserung normaler
eigenschaften von normal gesunden
menschen daran sehen sie schon an dieser
doch sehr weiten definition des
enhancement sehen sie schon dass man für
die bestimmung dessen was als ein
halsband betrachtet werden soll ein
konzept der menschlichen normal natur
benötigt hier fungiert die menschliche
natur als eine definitorischen normen
und das heißt jetzt nicht viel mehr als
ein statistisch verallgemeinerte
bezugspunkt von dem aus von
verbesserungen und in hahns nennt aber
übrigens auch von verschlechterungen von
krankheit und von funktionsstörungen
gesprochen werden kann
ich brauche auch die medizin ein konzept
der menschlichen normal natur
einige teile dieses konzept sind
historisch und kulturell kontingent und
das erschließt sich zum beispiel aus
medizin historischer oder
kulturwissenschaftlicher perspektive
sehr klar
andere teile dieses konzepts erscheinen
uns hingegen als in riad als
strukturelle eigenschaften der
charakteristischen menschlichen lebens
form meint es zum beispiel eine
begrenzte dauer des menschlichen lebens
und ein bekanntes weil auch empirisch
valides spektrum dessen was der mensch
aufgrund seiner körperlichen und
geistigen fähigkeiten überhaupt vermag
dieses mahnung erscheint uns als etwas
gegeben was ist aus
evolutionsbiologischer perspektive
evident nicht ist aber diese gegebenheit
heißt jetzt mich viel mehr als dass die
strukturellen eigenschaften der
charakteristischen menschlichen lebens
form für uns das heißt durch unseren
seen und unsere handlungen nicht
grundsätzlich veränderbare und von daher
quasi naturalistische hürden für unsere
selbstbeschreibung und unser
selbstverständnis darstellen bislang
endete nämlich alle bemühungen und alle
sehnsüchte zur beherrschung veränderung
gar überwindung der eigenen natur an
diesen unüberwindbaren hürden für das
was wir mit unserer sterblichen
schmerzlichen begrenzten verfassung aus
und selber machen können und zugleich
ist es eben dieses humanum dass durch
das human enhancement herausgefordert
wird
insofern einige biotechnologische
interventionsmöglichkeiten und zwar
insbesondere das neuro enhancement und
die gentechnik so radikal und
unumkehrbar sind dass sie tiefer gehende
hre und deswegen auch schwerwiegendere
möglichkeiten der menschlichen
selbstgestaltung eröffnen als uns aus
unserer kultur und
zivilisationsgeschichte ohnehin schon
bekannt ist
eigenschaften fähigkeiten merkmale die
man bis jetzt als typisch menschliche
charakteristischer betrachtet hat
könnten mittelfristig durch individuelle
und kollektive in hahns mit praktiken
verändert und derart dass durch
charakteristische menschliche
bestimmungen und natürliche begrenzung
bestimmte humanum grundlegend und
nachhaltig verifiziert werden
mit blick auf ganz bestimmung der
philosophischen anthropologie
ich zitiere die physiologische
menschenkenntnis geht auf die
erforschung dessen was die natur aus dem
menschen macht die pragmatische oder
eben genuin philosophische anthropologie
auf das was er als frei handelndes wesen
aus sich selber macht oder machen kann
und soll also mit stimmung mit denen
sich auf diese bestimmung können wir
sagen dass die herausforderung des
jungen in hahns mit darin besteht dass
die unterscheidung zwischen dem was die
natur aus uns macht dem was wir aus uns
machen dann erste natur zweite natur und
dem was wir herstellen zunehmend
unscharfe insofern wir als frei handeln
gewesen in die lage versetzt sind aus
unserer eigenen natur allerlei machen zu
können
ob der mensch solche mutmaßlichen
verbesserungen an sich selbst vornehmen
darf und wenn ja auf welche weise aus
welchem grünen in welchem ausmaß das
wird ja in dieser debatte mit rückgriff
auf geläufige ethische politik ethische
prinzipien risiko dammbruch autonomie
nicht schädigung gerechtigkeit intensiv
diskutiert aber auch darüber werde ich
heute nicht sprechen sondern eine
besonders radikale position aufgreifen
und skizzieren stichwort fiel schon auch
von herrn stroh man nämlich der
sogenannte trans hohmann ismus der auch
eine seriöse philosophische variante hat
und sich hier als eine fortsetzung des
humanismus versteht aber dann
ironischerweise die überwindung der
menschlichen lebens form des humanum
intendiert möchte daran einen einwand
diskutieren der mir besonders raffiniert
zu sein scheint dass der trans mannis
muss nämlich wenn man ihn ernst nimmt
und das werde ich tun die von ihnen
selbst vorgebrachten gründe für die
eigene normative attraktivität und
geltung scruff untergräbt anders gesagt
dass eine transformers tische ethik
weder ethik noch humanistisch wäre mit
diesen überlegungen hoffe ich
weiterzukommen bezüglich der frage ob
die anthropologie ein wissen über den
menschen bedeutet oder bereitstellt das
für normative fragestellung relevant
oder gar unverzichtbar ist als trans
mannis muss bezeichnet man die position
die die evolutionäre und die kulturelle
historizität und kontingenz der
menschlichen spezies nicht nur
feststellt sondern zum ausgangspunkt
nimmt für eine affirmative beurteilung
radikaler optimierende selbstgestaltung
neben den einsatz von konvergenz
technologie die dem in hand mit ja
ohnehin inhärente intention der
verbesserung wird hier zugespitzt
sozusagen zu so utopischen visionen von
prof humanen wesen die dem homo sapiens
sapiens in hinsicht auf seine
zahlreichen und übrigens auch von den
meisten menschen negativ beurteilten
eigenschaften und begrenzung nämlich
sterblichkeit kognitive und körperliche
grenzen emotionale trübung krankheiten
überlegen ist deutlich überlegen ist
one of the best das ist die zentrale
frage des transnistrischen programms das
allerdings wenn man jetzt dem
selbstverständnis der volt fans minister
association folgt keinen bruch mit
sondern eine fortschreibung der humanist
liberalen agenda bedeutet ich zitiere
aus dieser selbstdarstellung design
association schweiz jubel im st kombi
wird also extension of the making of
freedom tolerance democracy sehen dass
sich der trend man ist muss mit solchen
formulierungen in eine tradition stellt
in einer tradition der rationalen
selbstaufklärung und welt erschließung
mit den mitteln von wissenschaft und
technik die ihre wurzeln hat im
renaissance humanismus und wird einen
weiteren neuzeitlichen prozessen der
säkularisierung der individualisierung
das ganze beruht auf einem
unerschütterlichen und ja auch ziemlich
naiven vertrauen in die
selbstregulierenden kräfte und
moralischen potenziale der menschlichen
vernunft aber wie gesagt ich möchte den
leitgedanken des trans humanismus ernst
nehmen die menschliche unzufriedenheit
mit dem gegebenen und vor feindlichen
der wunsch sich zu verbessern
der wille wie auch die fähigkeit zur
selbstgestaltung und modifikation sind
doch teil unseres selbstverständnisses
mithin teil unserer natur die intention
der verbesserung die dem jungen in horn
smend inhärent ist gipfelt im
transformers muss in einer konsequenten
negation biologischer prozesse einfach
deswegen weil es diese biologie ist die
die vielfältigen einschränkungen und
behinderungen mängel und probleme der
menschlichen normal naturbedingt
gleichwohl sollen dem trans mann ist ist
trans humanistischen selbstverständnis
zufolge bestimmte freiheitlich
demokratische prinzipien des
zusammenlebens
verbindlich bleiben auch für die post
humane gesellschaft der trans humanismus
beansprucht demzufolge ein humanismus zu
sein
insofern die ethischen und politischen
normen der individualrechte der
autonomie der gleichberechtigung der
demokratie toleranz verantwortung seine
tragenden normativen säulen darstellen
und nun stellen sich verschiedene fragen
wenn ich lässt sich das psychologische
streben des trans humanismus
denn hier wird ja schlussendlich das
ende des menschen hin zu einer posthumen
zukunft angestrebt lässt sich das
eigentlich dauerhaft vereinbaren mit
diesem normativen rahmen des transform
an es muss hängt nicht vielmehr das was
wir für moralisch relevant halten welche
formen des lebens wir als gelungen und
vorbildlich oder misslungene und
unsittlich bewerten nicht auch davon ab
als welche art von wesen wir uns
verstehen welche bedürfnisse und ängste
wir teilen oder für besonders zentrale
achten welche charakteristischen
konflikte die zwischen menschen
gewissermaßen zu erwarten sind wir durch
allgemeine regel entschärfen wollen sind
also die moralischen und politik
ethischen prinzipien mit denen sich auch
der trans mannis muss und erst recht die
weniger radikalen liberalen befürwortete
des jungen hearns mit identifizieren von
anthropologischen voraussetzungen
abhängig die durch eine radikale
umgestaltung der menschlichen
lebensformen zerstört werden würden was
ganz beachtlich dass eben dieser jürgen
habermas der der ende der 50er jahre die
anthropologie damals sind wegwischt als
eine falsche ideologie 50 jahre später
in den 2000er jahren ein buch mit dem
titel die zukunft der menschlichen natur
veröffentlicht wo er anfängt von einer
gattung des ethik zu sprechen
und genau die fragen die ich jetzt
formuliert habe aufzuwerfen
ein dritter teil anthropologie als
bedingung der möglichkeit von wissen von
menschen die frage nach den empirischen
und normativen anthropologischen
voraussetzungen philosophische theorien
macht schon immer ihre berechtigung
gehabt haben
aber solange die konstanten und quasi
naturalistischen begrenzungen des human
uns nicht ernsthaft zur menschlichen
verfügung standen war die kluft zwischen
dem wer wir sind was die natur aus uns
macht und dem was wir werden können was
wir sie tatsächlich aus oder mit uns
machen können nicht groß genug um eine
radikale transformation diesem sinne ein
ende des menschen für möglich zu
erachten
wenn wir nun die zukunftspotenziale
einer tiefgehenden nachhaltigen
gegebenenfalls unumkehrbaren
modifikation dieser menschlichen natur
und damit auch der menschlichen lebens
von ernst nehmen dann sollte die
philosophie die frage nach dem ende des
menschen zum anders sehen sich noch
einmal mit der anthropologischen
grundfrage und ihrem systematischen ort
im felde der philosophie auseinander zu
setzen und meine leitende these dass es
ihr eine forschungs these skizziert ein
programm für die vielleicht nächsten
jahre ist dass sowohl deskriptive
empirisch weil die dir bahre als auch
evaluationen bestimmten aspekt unsere
natürlichen fähigkeiten oder
möglichkeiten heraus stellende merkmale
der menschlichen lebens form eingehen in
moral philosophische und politik
ethische reflexion dass sie zumeist
implizit mit ihnen verwoben sind
diese anthropologische presse positionen
haben eine strukturierende funktion für
die normative theoriebildung insofern
sie gewissermaßen vorwegnehmen mit
welcher art von lebewesen welchem
spektrum an
haltens weisen entscheidungs und
handlungsweisen und welchen anwendungs
verhältnissen unsere theorien
philosophisch gerechnet wird dazu gehört
auf den ersten blick ganz banale dinge
welche aber weniger banal gegenwärtig
durch den möglichen einsatz von
konvergenz technologie zur disposition
stehen die charakteristische menschliche
lebensform ist durch sterblichkeit einen
spezifischen körper mit spezifischen
bedürfnissen verletzlichkeiten zwar
insbesondere die fähigkeit zum erleben
von freude und schmerz aber auch gewalt
fähigkeit und bestimmte kognitive
fähigkeiten charakterisiert das
eingebundensein in bestimmte lebens und
funktions prozesse natalie tät
adoleszenz erfahrung von gesundheit und
krankheit alter und tod sind ebenso dazu
zu zählen wie die fähigkeit innige
bindung und zwar sowohl fürsorgliche als
auch feindliche bindungen zu anderen
menschen und daraus resultierend
verschiedene formen des sozialen
zusammenlebens zu entwickeln aber
natürlich auch sein eigenes leben nach
eigenen vorstellungen führen zu können
diese anthropologische grundlage die
also dann insofern nicht normativ ist
als es keinen guten grund gibt weswegen
wir sterblich 2 bei nicht gewalttätig
oder schlaf bedürftig sein sollten oder
in irgendeiner zukunft bleiben sollten
diese anthropologische grundlage
fungiert als bedingung der möglichkeit
von normativen wissen insofern die idee
die regulative idee der einheit des
menschlichen auf ihr aufruf der
entscheidende unterschied zu essentiell
ist ischen anthropologin zum beispiel zu
martha nussbaum fähigkeiten ansatz
besteht darin dass milch die
strukturierende funktion
anthropologischer topoi für die
normative theoriebildung also eine meta
theoretisch
perspektive interessiert wohingegen
nußbaum mit den capabilities bereits
seine ethischen normen gefunden zu haben
meint anthropologie als bedingung der
möglichkeit von normativen wissen gibt
der normativen rechtfertigung aber nicht
schon ihren inhalt sondern nur eine
richtung einen rahmen
zum beispiel hat francis fukuyama auf
eine verschränkung der idee der
menschenrechte mit anthropologischen
tatsachen hingewiesen ich zitiere der
politiker equality and integration of
independence rest only imperio fact of
natural jungen equality michelle der
community auch wenn ich fukuyama es
essentiell ismus für ein philosophisch
nicht gangbaren weg halte öffnet eine
solche empirisch normativ hybride kommen
humanity womöglich eine neue perspektive
auf das alte problem der
universalisierung wir müssen uns doch
fragen ob die theorie und praxis der
allgemeinen gleichen unveräußerlichen
menschenrechte überhaupt ohne eine
vorstellung geteilter menschlichkeit
auskommt die sich wiederum einen kanon
von universellen menschlichen
eigenschaften und konstanten verdankt es
für uns doch fragen ob sich nicht
jedenfalls der kern liberale
abwehrrechte als etwa der schutz gegen
gewalteinwirkung auf das leben der
schutz der körperlichen und geistigen
unversehrtheit die garantie der
persönlichkeitsentfaltung ob das alles
nicht klarer weise auf die menschen
typische physische psychische leib
gestalt und damit auf eigenschaften und
fähigkeiten der humanen lebensform
rekurriert ja und ist das was wir durch
solche selbst identifizierung und durch
erfahrungen durch individuelle und
kollektive erfahrungen über den menschen
hinlänglich wissen über seinen schmerz
fähigkeit seine furcht vor menschen
gemacht
seine spezifischen physischen und
psychischen verletzbarkeit dass nicht
die voraussetzung für die normative
kraft der menschenrechtlichen verbote
von folter sklaverei rechts willkür
diskriminierung und so weiter in diese
richtung würde ich zum beispiel den
löwen simba von entwickler
interpretieren und weiterentwickeln
sie skizziert einen normativ
bescheidenen nichts desto weniger
gehaltvollen und universalistischen
ethischen und zugleich politischen
liberalismus auf der grundlage eines
geteilten wissens um das was menschen
einander antun können und wofür daher
jeder mensch vernünftigen grund hat
wovor daher jeder mensch vernünftigen
grund hat sich zu fürchten
zitiere weil das immer fair zu beginn
wie westlotto will ein rudel wölfe rico
ist kruzifix diese universelle furcht
vor grausamkeit und das resultierende
schutzbedürfnis haben ihren bezugspunkt
in einer bestimmten gemeinsamen
vorstellung über schmerzen und qualen
über gewalt fähigkeit über
instrumentalisiert und ohnmacht
letztendlich in einer geteilten
konzeption dessen wer und wie wir sind
und was wir von den anderen zu erwarten
und zu befürchten haben
daher handelt es sich bei einer solchen
minimalistisch und sie sehen schon eher
auf negativen anthropologischen
eigenschaften beruhenden politik ethik
eben nicht nur um einen universe oder
cosmopolitan sondern zuvorderst um einen
einstieg bei die trans minister
erwartung dass eine radikale
transformation der menschlichen normal
natur den menschenrechtlichen kern einer
ethik der freiheit und gleichheit
unbeschadet lasse das geht wirklich ins
leere
wortwörtlich ins leere denn
menschenrechte für cell box kann es
nicht geben
eine posthume zukunft können wir uns
eben nicht vorstellen und daher auch
nichts prognostizierenden bezug auf die
moralischen politischen sozialen norm
die diese anderen für sich als angenehm
als angemessen und legitim erweisen wird
was allerdings für uns ethisch
angemessen und politisch legitim ist das
hat alle voraussetzungen darin wer wir
sind und als was wir uns verstehen
in diesem sinne sind humanität und
humanismus anthropologie und ethik
miteinander verknüpft das möchte ich
jetzt jeden fall zur diskussion stellen
und danke ihnen schon mal für die
aufmerksamkeit